-Our next guest is the host
of "Love About Town,"
available at Apple Podcasts.
Making her television debut,
please welcome the very funny
Kenice Mobley.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello. Hello. Hi. Hi.
I see a couple of men here.
A couple.
I do need to warn
all of the men, okay?
The second all this is over,
I'm making out
with everyone, okay?
Everyone.
I saw a couple
kissing on the street,
and my first thought was,
"Let me get in on that."
They did not like that. Okay.
They don't like it
when you say that to them.
They're against it.
I am single right now, okay,
at this moment.
But according to rom-com logic,
I did go up to my roof
and I shouted,
"I don't need a man!"
and, "I never want
to get married!"
So he should be coming
at any moment. Okay?
Do you guys, like,
hear a helicopter?
I think he's on his way.
I just --
I feel confident about it.
Look, truly, I don't know
if I ever want to get married,
but I do know
that I want my death
to ruin a man's life...
to the point where
he has to do paperwork.
That's important to me. It is.
It's very important to me.
I do see people I date
from time to time.
I told my mom about one
of the guys that I'm seeing,
and she was like,
"Oh, that's nice, Kenice,
but, um, quick question.
Is he...
or...?"
Some of you look
a little confused.
Yes, this is the white side
of my hand,
this is the black side
of my hand.
-Woman: Whoo!
-Yes, yes, yes.
Which -- I think it's funny
that, to my mom,
there are only
two races of people.
What I actually said was,
"Why, yes, Mom!
This time I got one with hands
and everything, so..."
No, me and that guy
pretty seriously
had the family conversation
where I was talking about
starting one
and he was letting me know
that he already had a wife and
child, so fun times, fun times.
Completely unrelated question --
where do you guys stand
on dogs with people names?
Some shrugging.
Some side to side.
I don't know what that means.
Okay, it's a mix.
It's a mix. All right.
I am for it, okay?
I am for it.
I am for it because I think
it makes it clear
who is okay with slavery.
[ Laughter ]
No, because if you are willing
to take a living being,
you know, and name it Stephanie
and put it in your basement
and tell it when it can eat
and who it can love,
I just don't think that's a far
stretch to owning people, okay?
I think about slavery a lot.
Because as I'm walking around,
minding my own business,
I am constantly told
that I look like different
civil-rights activists.
[ Scattered laughter ]
And it needs to stop.
That's rude that people
would say that to me.
And I will take
a smattering of laughter
because what happens far too
often is a roomful of people
who just start shouting out
suggestions.
Just "Sojourner Truth!
Ida B. Wells! Bessie Coleman!"
The one that I get the most,
the one that I've gotten
five times this year is that
I look like Harriet Tubman.
-Woman: Aww.
-I will take -- Aww. Thank you.
I will take your, "Aww, no,"
because what's happened
far too often --
Recently, it was terrible.
A man just was like...
"Yes! Ohh!"
Like he had been sitting there
my whole set like,
"Mnh-mnh, mnh-mnh, mnh-mnh.
No.
Why do I think of emancipation
every time I look
at that woman?"
And I explained it to him,
and he felt seen
and I felt deeply hurt.
It's frustrating
for a lot of reasons.
One, because when people are
thinking of Harriet Tubman,
they're thinking
of an illustration.
An illustration
of an 80-year-old woman.
And it's like I know
I look tired, okay?
I know, I know.
But is this the type of
exhaustion that could only come
from picking cotton in a field?
Is that --
Is that what my face is giving?
And people are like,
"Come on, Kenice, no.
It's the glasses.
It's the glasses."
And it's like,
"Oh, o-okay, it's...
it's just that Harriet Tubman
didn't wear glasses."
[ Laughter ]
What would she need them for?
All that reading
she couldn't do?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kenice Mobley.
For more info,
go to kenicemobley.com.